[Music]
I'm Victoria Lancia and I'm the owner of
panzerotti bytes with my husband
Pasquale
so panzerotto is a specialty food from
Puglia which is the heel of the boot of
Italy panzerotti is very similar to a
calzone but it is different because of
the dough the dough is very light is
highly digestible so you can eat more
instead of just eating one calzone you
can try different panzerotti and we fry
panzerotti because this is the
traditional way that people eat and
prepare panzerotti but even if it is
fried it is not greasy nor oily and we
import a lot of ingredients from Puglia
or from italy to make the authentic
panzerotti here in new york panzerotti
is a street food so you can eat you must
eat with your hands
paying attention not to make a mess in
your clothes because sometimes the
mozzarella and the tomato sauce can fall
so you should eat like this or like
these bite after bite
so to make fun 0 2 you can roll down the
dough and then you can add some sweet or
savory ingredients then you fold it up
and then you can fry it
the panzerotti dough is very similar to
the pizza dough is made of extra virgin
olive oil salt water fresh yeast and
zero-zero flour that we import from
Italy we prepare the dough in the dough
mixer and then we can cut small pieces
with them and then make a little ball
with our ends and then we move them to
the refrigerator for 48 hours everyone
from Puglia or from italy knows the
classic pan zero team so to prepare a
classic panzerotto you have to roll down
the dough put some fresh mozzarella a
little bit of tomato sauce and then a
little bit of oregano and then you can
close the panzerotto in a house moon
shape it with your hands you can close
borders and then you can fry it here in
New York we are also offering a new
version of panzerotti which is called
guru my panzerotto so the difference is
that the gourmet is fried empty and then
afterwards we cut in half and put some
fresh ingredients so it will look like a
sandwich and we customize the panzerotto
with an iron so if you can always
recognize that that is a panzerotto from
panzer device
[Music]
panzerotti means a lot for boolean
people it has part of our life of our
story so for us even if it is very
similar in the shape of an empanada or a
calzone our dumplings panzerotti is a
unique food it can't be compared to
anything else
[Music]